if you guys don't know who shake is he
is the uh villain from love is blind
season two
um
i i did a bit of a breakdown on the show
on a on a prior podcast live a few weeks
ago and then i got a message from you uh
afterwards saying that you had seen it
that you know you wanted to chop it up
and that you appreciated the way that i
sort of framed um
the reality of what the show was and the
way that you handled it
what was your experience on that show
like
you know for for those that saw it on
the outside they saw the version that
they wanted to tell
but
from your end like is it something that
you would do again or was it like a
colossal waste of time for you
uh i i wouldn't do it again um
but it also wasn't a colossal waste of
time you know i i certainly
enjoyed a lot of it it was a fun
experience i'll say
um
being
part of such a like a huge production
you know what i mean
um but you say huge like like what's
huge like how many people were
involved with the studio
a lot you know um it just seemed
yeah uh because we were in a few
different locations we started
in la or outside la for the the pods and
then we were in mexico and then we were
in chicago
and while a few people remain constant
throughout that
it's like throughout throughout each
stage we'd have like a bunch of new
people suddenly show up and then like
they'd be gone and then you know they'd
be replaced by somebody else so
all in all it was a lot of people a lot
of you know a lot of camera people
lighting people some of the producers
were pretty constant throughout but
um it was fun it was cool and it wasn't
until
i saw
my
edit that i was like okay wow this is
[ __ ]
during during the actual filming i'm
like this is great this is going great
guys like what are you talking about
it was that different from your actual
experience like the final edit that we
saw was was that different from from
what you perceive to be like your
reality at the time like they can
you know they can skew it with what they
decide to show obviously and how they
present you know what it is that they're
showing leading up to that right
yeah that's that's basically right i
mean um i'll put it to you this way we
were all great friends up until
the show
came out you know and even even
halfway through the show being out we
were all friends so for example
one week before the reunion was filmed
actually it was less than a week um it
was super bowl sunday and i watched the
super bowl with
shane
uh kyle and deeps my ex-fiance we
watched it together so
i mean
that should show that there was at least
some camaraderie there we were still on
decent terms
um
but it's
it's when the cameras turned on for the
reunion that everybody started kind of
like
you know
going after
i was gonna say going after each other
but it was really really just going
after me i would say
um because i was kind of just
without a doubt the villain of the show
to everybody and it was like hey if if i
throw shade at this guy maybe everyone
else is gonna think i'm a good person
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you